ever feel like the earth is just too
small
well let's make it bigger
much much bigger
welcome to a new earth that is just as
big as jupiter
in what ways would earth change
what things would stay the same
and how would this affect you
this is what if and here's what would
happen if earth were the size of jupiter
a super earth is a planet with a mass up
to 10 times bigger than the earth but
don't let the name deceive you
these super earths
aren't anything like the earth you know
these planets could be rocky or covered
entirely in ice
they could even be gaseous like neptune
but if you want to make the earth as big
as jupiter
get ready to make a super super super
earth
but before this earth gets out of hand
let's talk about today's sponsor
grammarly you know sometimes writing
tasks can feel as massive as jupiter but
with grammarly premium i have the
confidence i need to take on these
everyday chores so whether i'm sending a
text or writing a script all my word
choices come across clear and concise
and it works on all my devices so i
never have to sacrifice quality in my
communication i can even adjust the
settings to fit my writing style and
recommend vocabulary suggestions
cut down on editing time and write more
confidently with grammarly premium and
right now get twenty percent off
grammarly premium by signing up at
grammarly.com slash what if that's 20
off at g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y
dot com slash what if
you know there's only one thing bigger
than this deal
and it's coming up now
while earth as it exists now is much
smaller than jupiter
it is a pretty dense rock compared to
the gas giant
our new planet would be massive
about
1300 times bigger than earth today
and that's not the only thing that would
be different
jupiter has a radius about 11 times that
of earth
get used to a little more gravity when
you walk around
yeah 11 times more
so
if earth was this huge
how soon would the gravity completely
crush your body
this change in size would have enormous
implications for you and all other life
on earth
the first thing you'd notice with 11
times the surface gravity is
that you would weigh more
and there's not much a diet plan could
do to change that
you'd be 11 times heavier than you are
now
so if you currently weigh 70 kilograms
well get ready to start lugging a hefty
770 kilograms around
would you even be strong enough to carry
your own weight
well you'd be heavier than the world
deadlifting record of 501 kilograms held
by game of thrones star halfthor
bjornsson so yeah good luck
but if you were a couch potato this
could be good news getting up from the
couch wouldn't be an option
you wouldn't have the muscle strength
even breathing would be a near
impossible task
scientists have concluded that the
maximum gravitational field that humans
could adapt to is about five times the
gravity of earth
well now double that and that would be
your new normal
and you wouldn't be the only one feeling
heavier all that gravity would result in
increased atmospheric pressure
yeah you'd feel the air pressing down on
you
this would have severe environmental
impacts
water molecules would need more energy
to escape their liquid form
that means the boiling temperature of
water would be much higher than 100
degrees
and the freezing point would now be way
below zero degrees
it would be harder for you to make ice
and even the large chunks of ice like
icebergs could melt away
and there would be disruptions beyond
life on the surface of earth
introducing a massive planet into the
solar system would create some serious
instabilities
our moon would experience extreme
changes in tidal forces
this gravity could be strong enough to
pull the moon apart into teeny tiny
pieces
the only remnant you'd have left would
be a new ring of debris forming around
earth
the sun would still be
250 times more massive than our new
earth so earth wouldn't steal any
planets away but our super earth could
have some effect on their orbit
just as venus and jupiter impact our
orbit and climate today
the earth would affect the orbits of
other celestial bodies like asteroids
our gravitational pull could be strong
enough to eject these objects from the
asteroid belt and set them on a
collision path with you
and
that would be bad news
remember
you wouldn't be able to move a muscle to
escape
so
maybe it's better if earth stays the
same size as it is now
or maybe it could be even bigger
like the sun but that's a story
for another
what if